[موسيقى]
اختفاء واطنان من المساعدات بالسودان
وملايين الاطفال بخطر
الجيش اللبناني يحرر مواطنا سعوديا بعد
يومين على اختطافه
رائده الفضاء السعوديان ريان وعلي يبداان
رحله العوده الى الارض
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
نبدا معكم من السودان حيث كشف برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي التابع للامم المتحده عن
اختفاء 17 الف طن من المنتجات الغذائيه
المخصصه للمحتاجين في السودان بعد ان
تعرضت للنهب والسرقه منذ اندلاع الاقتتال
بين الجيش والدعم السريع مدير البرنامج
قال ان قيمه الخسائر تقدر بما يعادل نحو
14 مليون دولار وبالتسامه مع ذلك اعلنت
منظمه الامم المتحده لطفوله يونيوسف ان
اكثر من
13.6 مليون طفل سوداني بحاجه ماسه لدعم
الانساني عشيره الى ان وضعهم بلغ مستويات
كارثيه نتيجه الصراع الدائري في البلاد
بعد نحو 48 ساعه تقريبا على خطفه اعلن
الجيش اللبناني تحرير المواطن السعودي
مشاري المطيري الذي اختفى في بيروت قبل
يومين الجيش اوضح في بيان ان دوريه من
مديريه المخابرات تمكنت من تحرير المخطوف
بعد عمليه النوعيه على الحدود اللبنانيه
السوريه مشيرا الى توقيف عدد من المتورطين
في عمليه الخطف في مكانه عائله المخطوف قد
تلقى اتصالا من رقم هاتف طالبه فيه طالما
خاطفه بمبلغ 400 الف دولار لقاء تحريره
[موسيقى]
بعد عشره ايام على استكشاف الفضاء واجراء
التجارب العلميه اختتم رائد الفضاء
السعوديان ريان برناوي وعلي القرني
مهمتهما في محطه الفضاء الدوليه وبدا رحله
العوده الى الارض هيئه الفضاء السعوديه
بثت مقطعا مصورا على تويتر يظهر اللحظات
الاخيره في محطه الفضاء بعد انتهاء المهمه
العلميه لرائدي الفضاء السعوديين فيما
بدات دراجون المركبه التي تقلهما
وزميليهما الامريكيين
رحله العوده التي تستغرق نحو 13 ساعه قبل
الوصول الى المياه
والى عالم التكنولوجيا هذه المره حيث من
المتوقع ان تطرح شركه متى نظرتها الذكيه
بتصميم مختلف ومزايا جديده سيتم ذلك في
مؤتمر الشركه السنوي للواقع المعزز
والافتراض المقرر عقده في اكتوبر المقبل
وكالته ذكرت ان الجيل الجديد للنظاره
سيكون اكثر تطورا اخف وزنا وفيها مستشعر
الوان دقيق يتيح للمستخدمين القدره على
رؤيه ما حولهم بشكل طبيعي وتفاعل معه دون
الحاجه لخلع النظاره وهو مكان مستحيلا في
الجيل السابق من
[موسيقى]
نختتم معكم من هذا الخبر اللافت الذي
شهدته الاراضي الفلسطينيه وضجه به التواصل
الاجتماعي حيث اعلن الشاب يدعى عمار عابد
زواجه بعد 20 عاما من خطبته
في عام 2002 اعتقل عمار البالغ من العمر
19 عاما حينها من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه
وذلك بعد ايام قليله من عقد قرانه لتحكم
عليه محكمه اسرائيليه بالسجن لمده 17 عاما
فيما تم تمديد سجنه ثلاثه اعوام ونصف
اضافيه في عام 2014 ومع ذلك اصرت خطيبتها
على ان تنتظره كل هذه المده ليتزوجا اخيرا
وسط اصوات زغاريد نساء العائله
[موسيقى]